I want to do something that
matters.
♪♪
Emily, you're a poet.
You work so hard on your poems.
You want every line to be
perfect.
But I want the mess.
I want you.
♪♪
Emily:
This is a very dark time.
The violence.
Emily:
The suffering.
♪♪
Emily:
That's what I want to heal,
with my poetry.
Words don't matter right now.
♪♪
I have so much poetry in my
head.
Emily:
With all this conflict, none of
it has been able to come out.
This family is a joke.
My marriage is a lie.
Civil war ruins everything.
♪♪
This war just came out of
nowhere.
I'm not sure about that.
I think it was pretty clear we
were headed in a bad direction.
♪♪
You're really the only one brave
enough to face the truth.
♪♪
You're not trying to peddle some
false hope.
What if hope is all we have?
♪♪
My family is in complete chaos.
Emily:
But nothing I do seems to be making
anything any better.
♪♪
You think you're fighting for
something, but really
you're just running away.
♪♪
To be a great poet, you have to
feel everything.
Walt Whitman:
The pleasure, the pain,
the sunlight, the shade.
Yeah, he just takes it a little
bit too far.
Yesssss!
Death:
Come on, now.
Where do you get that fire from?
♪♪
Emily:
I can't live without you.
I can't breathe without you.
♪♪
I want to do something that
matters.
♪♪
Don't worry, everyone.
Emily Dickinson is here to help.
♪♪
In the future, you're actually
famous.
Emily Dickinson was the original
sad girl.